good day everyone and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia please allow me
to welcome you to this edition of our 2020 2021
foundations of biomedical data science seminar
series this lecture is supported by uva's
integrated translational health institute
of virginia the uva brain institute the college
of arts and sciences the school of data science
and through a grant from the national institutes
of general medical sciences it is my honor and
privilege today to welcome our speaker dr maryann
martone from the fair data informatics lab at the
university of california san diego dr martone
received her bachelor of arts from wellesley
college in biological psychology and ancient greek
and her phd in neuroscience from the university
of california san diego she is a professor
emeritus at us ucsd but maintains an active
laboratory and currently serves as chair of the
university of california academic senate committee
on academic computing and communications she
began her career as a neuroanatomist specializing
in light in electron micro microscopy but her main
research for the past two decades has been focused
on the informatics associated with neuroscience
she's led the neuroscience informatic excuse me
the neuroscience information framework the nif a
national project to establish a uniform resource
uh description framework for neuroscience and the
niddk information network or the dknet a portal
for connecting researchers in digestive kidney
and metabolic diseases to data tools and materials
she served for five years as the editor-in-chief
of brain and behavior and open access journal
and has just launched a new journal as
editor-in-chief called neuro commons dr martone
is the past president of the force 11 task force
an organization dedicated to advancing scholarly
communication and e scholarship she's completed
a two-year uh stint as the chair of the on the
council of training science and infrastructure for
the international neuro informatics coordinating
facility based in stockholm sweden and serves
as the chair of their governing board since
quote-unquote retiring as an emerita professor at
ucsd she has served as the director of biological
sciences for hypothesis a technology nonprofit um
developing an open annotation layer for the web
and founded cycrunch a technology startup
based on technologies developed through the
nif and the dknet projects dr martone's lecture
today is entitled the use of ontologies for fair
neuroscience and as always we are streaming this
lecture live and for recording via youtube if
you are watching via youtube thank you so much
for joining us also our specially selected 2021
uh biomedical data science innovation lab
participants are encouraged to submit any
questions for dr martone by the chat feature
in their zoom sessions i will synthesize the
questions and i will ask them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so of the lecture
and with that welcome maryann thank you so much
we are really looking forward to your lecture
oh thank you so much jack for inviting me and
i'm really looking forward to presenting to you
on this topic that has occupied me for as you'll
see many many years i just wanted to wave to you
live but then i'm going to turn off my video
so you don't have to be distracted by my little
moving face uh and let me start my timer to make
sure that i don't go over so let's see oops i'm in
the wrong place there we go okay so this is not
a typo at the top of the slide i didn't forget
to put something in but i always start or any
lecture that you hear on neuroscience and the
data and informatics challenges of neuroscience
always starts with some version of this slide and
that's why i put it here it basically means
they will show you all the different scales
over which neuroscience needs to be understood
from the level of the behaving animal down to
the subcellular and molecular level over here let
me minimize this individual molecules it talks
about the different modalities of data that we
need to acquire from light and electron microscopy
to physiology traces to behavioral data so we know
that neuroscience data is complex and it therefore
presents unique challenges when trying to develop
data sharing platforms data sharing strategies and
uh fair data approaches to neuroscience so just
to summarize it's a diverse experimental domain
with very complex experimental paradigms has to
traverse multiple temporal and spatial scales
there is no dominant model system people work
on all sorts of organisms all over the place
very heavily reliant on spatial information so
imaging brain atlas is common coordinate systems
and technology and the the new technology is
constantly being developed and the impact of
this technology can be transformative in the
understanding of structure and function of
the brain so what we know about the brain is
very much dependent on the techniques that we
use to probe it and when i was in graduate
school one of my professors introduced this
phrase of disputed origin the gain in brain
lies mainly in the stain and what that meant was
that if you look at great leaps in neuroscience
such as cahal's neuron theory it was really due
to different ways of probing the nervous system
and being able to visualize them so for our
topic today which is ontology uh the result of the
nature of neuroscience the history of neuroscience
and the heavy technological flux is that there's
an extraordinarily large number of vocabularies
that people use to describe this organ so
clearly neuroscience needs to be fair right
if one is going to be able to acquire this data
using these different techniques across the globe
no one laboratory or no one group or no
one country is uniquely able to acquire
all the data that they need you need to
be able to somehow put this data together
and if you want to put this together data together
of course you have to be able to find it you've
got to be able to access it you need to be able
to reuse it and we'd like at some level if we're
going to traverse these scales to make sure that
this data is at least some level interoperable
that is i can take results that come from lab
1 results from lab 2 and put them together
in some way doesn't mean that they're consistent
and that will be a constant theme of my talk it
just means that i at least have a shot at being
able to take this data put it together and look
to see if i can build an integrated picture of the
way that the brain works so i'm not going to focus
on the far parts of fair i'm going to focus
exclusively here on the interoperability part and
if we look at that in more detail we see that it
asks for several things it asks for metadata and
data to use a formal accessible shared and broadly
applicable language for knowledge representation
those who know the people who are behind fair
assume that they're talking about something like
rdf the resource description framework but in fact
they constantly say that that is not true that
it is agnostic but it shouldn't be custom
and it shouldn't be proprietary it should
be something that is is available to everyone
and that can translate some of these things
into a knowledge representation it should use
vocabularies that themselves follow the fair
principles and we'll talk about what that means in
just a moment and it should also include qualified
references explicit references meaningful
references to other data so this idea of being
able to link across things means that if i have
two pieces of information in two different places
what is the relationship between those and that
should be ideally in a machine computable form
so what is a fair vocabulary well essentially it
has the characteristics of fair data and fair data
if i'm sure you're familiar with the principles
have these persistent identifiers which uniquely
identify a particular thing that unique identifier
ties metadata about that thing whether it's a data
file whether it's an article to that persistent
identifier it has relationships to other things
as we just talked about and in the realm
of computer science and data science really
uh these things are characteristic of those
structures that we call ontologies and
also controlled vocabularies in its broadest sense
ontologies are representations of human knowledge
that are machine computable at least that's how
we use it in data science and over here you see
an example from a community ontology called
uberon which is anatomical ontology there's
a preferred name it's got an identifier a full
uri it's got relationships to other things it's
got mappings to other identifier systems and this
would be what we would consider a fair ontology
a fair vocabulary because it is represented in
owl ii which is a a common interchange language
for ontologies that let some sort of reasoning and
other operations be performed on this vocabulary
so just again by way of introduction what is an
ontology i sort of introduced it already i assume
many are familiar with this but in its formal
definition an ontology is an explicit formal
representation of concepts relationships among
them within a particular domain that express human
knowledge in a machine-readable form in philosophy
however an ontology is a theory of what is and
one of the themes of this talk is that clashing
definitions between philosophy of a theory what
is with an experimental science like neuroscience
which is we don't know what is we're still trying
to find out is one of the reasons that it's been
somewhat difficult to actually build ontologies
for neuroscience but you can see a simple one
over here on the right brain has a part called
a cerebellum it has a purkinje cell layer which
has a part called a purkinje cell which is a type
neuron so basically you have these relationships
these concepts and the relationships between them
and we'd like to say that ontologies as i'll show
in a minute are uniquely crucial to neuroscience
because if you look at the data types that are
associated with neurons and molecules and the
data types that are associated perhaps with brain
the only thing that really relates them together
in many cases because you can't always resolve
individual neurons in the brain are these
conceptual networks that is no single data type
has all of this complexity in it at any given
time so that i think their unique neuroscience is
uniquely reliant on them as i'll show you in just
a moment so a lot of my introduction to ontologies
came through a project called the neuroscience
information framework which jack mentioned in the
introduction this project's been going on for a
long time it's actually before 2008 i know that
you're young faculty so many of you were probably
very young when we started this and it was an
initiative of something called the nih blueprint
consortium these are all the institutes
that are involved in neuroscience
who actually had been funding a lot of different
resources to produce databases and online tools
and materials and services and this predated
nih reporter predated a lot of things that
are now available for us to find these things
but basically it was very difficult to know
what resources were out there and available
to the neuroscience community so nif at its
heart was a cataloging exercise and we maintain a
very large catalog of these resources to find out
what is being built out there what domains
do they cover what don't they cover
and it also was an explicit charge for how can we
make them better in the future that is how can we
find these and how can we make them better in the
future so that essentially again they are fair
so this is just a slide a screen share screenshot
of the current interface of the nif that still
exists and still goes on one thing i do want to
just mention is that the technology platform it
has is built on has been rebranded cycrunch and
so if throughout this talk you hear references to
cycrunch that's what i'm talking about it's
basically the technology stack but it was
one of the first attempts to really federate in
quotes across independently developed maintained
databases and data sources so it turned
out when we did our catalog that there
were hundreds to thousands of these databases out
there broadly defined in neuroscience but a lot of
them just general biomedicine because everything
biomedical is pretty much relevant to each other
and nif initially was performed in the very much
pre-fair uh state so there were no standards
there were no desire to develop any standards and
there was certainly no desire to federate so nif
essentially created an index across data sets
as they were not as we would desire them to be
and of course you can imagine that it was quite
difficult there's an old saying the problem is as
i've seen this old saying across multiple domains
that researchers in bioinformatics would rather
use somebody else's toothbrush than somebody
else's code i've seen the same thing in molecular
biology with gene names and i've seen the same
thing in anatomy in terms of anatomical names
and that meant when you were actually going to try
to search across these things every variant of a
name that you could possibly think of was there
and every possible synonym for a name was there
so there was very little underlying similarity
between different data sources and how bad was
this i did a little analysis nif at the time
had seven databases that contained connectivity
information about either primary data or claims
from the literature that brain structure a
was connected to brain structure b and
if we looked across these seven sources
there were eighteen hundred unique brain
terms this doesn't include uh bird brain
terms and if you try to compare them that you saw
that the number of times that the exact same term
to describe a brain structure was present in more
than one database was 42. so 42 out of the 1800
unique brain terms had the same exact usage across
those if you added synonyms there were 99 of them
so some of them was just synonymous but if you
added the first order part tony matches you got up
to about 400. so what you saw was that people do
not use a common terminology to describe the same
brain structure but a lot of times they weren't
describing the entire brain structure they were
describing parts of that brain structure and
that that's what those relationships were so we
realized that in order to search sniff effectively
we needed some sort of ontology to sit behind
it that would help us navigate these synonyms
it would help us navigate these relationships
in order to provide more effective search and we
created something called the nif standard ontology
back in 2008 it still exists and is available in
bioportal and through nif and it was essentially
a collection of community ontologies these were
ontologies that existed out in the community
uber on we've referenced already gene ontology
you may be familiar with that covered the major
anatomical domains now in many cases they didn't
cover neuroscience particularly well and but they
were a good starting point to say okay here's a
list of brain regions here's a list of cell types
okay and nif did a lot of work to try to
improve the neuroscience coverage in a lot
of these as well so this was used in a bat as
a back end to the search enif so that if you
search nif for something like they called the
interior cingulate area it would expand into
a synonym remember there was no mapping the
people who created this were very reluctant or
unwilling to put identifiers into their
system so it was generally free text
and we had to disambiguate a lot of things but
essentially if you put this in you would get back
all the data that referenced one or more of these
terms now this wasn't perfect it was prone to
a lot of false positives cga for example is
gene but it did at least let us query broadly
across hundreds of information sources to see
what they had about the anterior cingulate but
you might say and this was a major concern to
the neuroscientists just because they said this
was from the anterior cingulate cortex were they
really meaning the same thing and the answer was
almost assuredly not which i'm going to show
you in a moment but what we try to convince
the neuroscientists is like look we're not trying
to get to the definitions here we're just trying
to say that if you are claiming that you have
something about the anterior cingulate cortex
if you're claiming that you have some data on this
or some knowledge about this we would like to know
about it so we're really not concerned uh whether
or not the usage of the term anterior cingulate
cortex was consistent across these rather
we were trying to track assertions about the
anterior cingular cortex but as i mentioned before
neuroscience has a lot of vocabularies and part
of a lot large reason why we have a lot of those
vocabularies is because the way that you break up
something called the anterior cingulate cortex or
even where it is is not in great agreement amongst
different groups so this is one of my favorite
slides to just illustrate one of the problems this
is a study that is on the prefrontal cortex of
the mouse this is just the mouse nothing else it's
just one chunk of cortex right in the beginning
right in front of the anterior cingulate in fact
there are six different parsilation schemes
that have been superimposed on this particular
piece of tissue based on one single technique
six different ones and if you bother to align
them together you see that they don't really align
they don't use the same vocabulary the lines don't
cross in the same place and so the relationships
between what one person says is anterior cingulate
and what its subparts are and what another says is
anterior cingulate is very dependent on technique
it's dependent on a whole bunch of different
factors but it is not an exaggeration to say
that these don't agree and this is not people
being obstinate it's that in fact we don't know
everyone who proposed one of these particulation
schemes had evidence that this in fact was
a an accurate representation of how you should
divide up this area of cortex and how you should
define its boundaries but they don't necessarily
agree so it turns out that in neuroscience that's
true for a lot of our knowledge what you would
consider fundamental knowledge so you might think
that by now since we the concept that neurons
are the cell types of the nervous system has
been around for 100 some odd years that we would
understand how many neuron types are in the brain
but in fact this was an announcement of the nih or
the u.s brain initiative back in 2014 uh and one
of the things they said was the mammalian brain
contact contains a vast number of cells they're
generally grouped by broad classes but it is
currently unknown exactly how many classes exist
so in fact when people disagree about what cell
types comprise a region again they're not being
just obstinate it's that we honestly don't know so
if you're going to take knowledge about a domain
and formalize it it would help that you understood
what knowledge you were actually formalizing
and what we learned over the years when we were
trying to use uh common procedures that were in
place for building very successful ontologies like
the gene ontology was that they really didn't work
because that sort of what they normally do is
they would get a bunch of experts in the room
and everybody would agree that these were the
brain regions and this is how they were organized
and no amount of sitting in a room trying to gain
consensus on a cell type or brain region is going
to work we've tried we've tried for many years
and that's because again it's simply not known
it's not that there is not shared knowledge so the
fact if you look at the neuroscience literature
you will see things like pyramidal cell and
you'll see things like anterior cingulate cortex
it just doesn't go very deep so we have a shared
conceptualization of neuroscience we can talk to
each other we can teach neuroscience to each other
but if you then try to go into the particulars you
find that these more granular concepts which are
really critical for annotating experimental data
are almost completely reliant on specific
experimental techniques and even then as in
the case of the nissel they may not be adequate to
get to anything that we may consider ground truth
there may not be a ground truth i think we have
to also you know kind of uh a grapple with that so
it when nif was going ahead and trying to build
these ontologies we really uh we we started to
understand that the typical way of doing this
was not going to work and something that was much
more flexible and respected the fact that on that
neuroscience was really an experimental domain we
were on the cutting edge of trying to figure out
how this tissue was organized was needed so in
the next part of the talk i'm going to go through
uh the strategies and infrastructures that we've
developed over the years for using and building
in neuroscience ontologies and how they are being
applied now across three projects the first is the
brain initiative cell census network these are the
groups of neuroscientists who are trying to use
cutting-edge techniques to gain a handle on how
many cell types are there and i'm going to talk
about how we're representing neuron phenotypes
using ontologies as a way to translate between
experimental science and general knowledge
i'm going to talk about the stimulating peripheral
activity to relieve conditions or spark project
this is a large project that's trying to map
the autonomic nervous system and we're using
and extending anatomical ontologies uh across data
models and circuitry diagrams to build a cohesive
platform in a large knowledge base and if i have
time i'll get into the reprint project which is
reproducible neuroimaging and their
concept of federated data elements
i understand that if i don't get to reaper name
david kennedy who leads that project is coming
soon so he will be able to pick up where i left
off so let's start with the neuron phenotype
ontology or as i like to say how to have fair
disagreements this is really the work of tom
gillespie was a graduate student in my lab and
shawn hill our colleague at the blue brain project
and uh it was designed again to have a to deal
with this fact that since we don't know how many
cell types there are in the nervous system how
do we gain some traction on representing and
translating amongst the different classification
schemes that have been generated so if you look
at neuron classification schemes this is
where somebody goes into a brain region and
based on some set of properties says well i think
that there's five major cell classes the problem
of gabaergic interneurons in the cortex which
is just one region of the brain has literally
generated in the last few years dozens and dozens
of different classification schemes that have been
proposed for them they usually measure a set
of process of properties a lot of experimental
data they distill that down into some sort of
proposal which is usually presented as a table
and of course everybody has its own table we
know that some of these are due to experimental
artifacts or the fact that group a measured
these sets of phenotypes and group b measured
these sets of phenotypes but we'd like to think
that inside of all this data it is trying to
come to the conclusion that there are in
fact discrete cell types that transcend
any one of these techniques right some
sort of universal knowledge about this
but again the way that this data is typically
published and this is meant to overwhelm and
confuse is that you distill down all this
different experimental data that you see
you get this table and then you're supposed to
be able to compare across these tables i can't
think of anything more unfair than the way that
we turn currently communicate about cell types
in the nervous system so the neuron phenotype
ontology was designed uh as a common data model
for expressing neuronal types as extension collect
extensible collections of phenotypes essentially
taking those tables and turning it into something
that is interoperable according to the fair data
principles and the way that we had to do this was
sort of abandon uh a realist perspective on the
fact that there is a neuron and there's only one
type of neuron we're trying to get to those types
that they're talking about here and just recognize
that a lot of times all we have are classes of
neurons that are a bunch of phenotypic properties
so we basically decided to embrace the reality
of the way neuroscience is done instead of the
way that we were taught to develop ontologies
which means i have to tie very closely to some
universal realistic perspective of what's there
so neurons themselves are modeled as bags
of phenotypes these phenotypes come from
major ontologies so they have identifiers they're
fair they're species there's anatomical molecular
morphological physiological but we define two
different types something that we call common
usage type which is typically the thing that's
covered in an ontology these are things that
have been studied by hundreds of labs over the
years they are recognized across multiple species
it doesn't really matter whether you use a
particular technique there are multiple techniques
that allow you to develop them so they've really
passed into common knowledge but we distinguish
that with what we call these evidence-based
models or evidence-based types and these are ones
that again represent what you saw in the previous
slides these are groups of people usually sets of
experiments or projects that have employed a set
of set techniques they've gone ahead and created a
classification scheme and they want to communicate
that and the evidence-based type again differs in
several fundamental ways from the common usage
type the common usage type is generally species
and species independent that is you will find
them across multiple species a pyramidal cell is
the pyramidal cell's pyramidal cell and you see it
across multiple species they typically again come
from a specified source which is a laboratory
a project so you can trace the provenance back
to an individual group whereas you can for some of
these common uterus types say the first person who
described it but they generally didn't describe
it in totality right this represents the general
work of the community to understand what this
common neutral type is it always comes from a
specific species and strain because that's what
that group is studied so it's tied very closely
to an individual species the class definitions are
driven by data they've actually been collecting
data on this and what we've done is we've taken
a set of python scripts and that allow you to
take the phenotypes that have been collected
by that laboratory that would be in that table
and turn that into a more formal representation
using owl semantics the web ontology language
that actually relates those phenotypes to
individual ontologies through their identifiers
so it says you can say whatever you want about
this we will give you something that lets you
uh convert your uh names into owl statements so
this is all done automatically through python
and then we can generate automatically a
consistent naming scheme for these neurons
based on these phenotypic properties which
right now looks like this just long string
almost like a gene sequence of all of the
different phenotypical characters that go
into defining this neuron class so you see
species anatomy morphology electrophysiology
this is all done automatically again nobody
needs to do anything so this differs from a
lot of the ways that common naming schemes
are put in where you get agreement from
a group of experts that say this is how you're
going to name it and then you manually go
and follow that scheme these are all done
automatically and handled through the ontology
so these evidence-based types tie very closely
to what it is that the experimentalists reported
and that means that if you actually look at these
names in their reality they can be quite messy so
these are all the same entities that are color
coded according to different schemes josh huang
henry markrum allen brain and s1 is the primary
somatosensory cortex it's called neocortex and
wong it's primary visual cortex here that comes
from a specific atlas in the allen this one is our
common usage type which says well generally these
cells are found in neocortex layer two and three
and you can see that all of them seem to have
something to do with the neurotransmitter gaba
but this one has gaba receptors this one has gaba
channels this one has the actual neurotransmitter
gaba and so on and so forth so when you look
at the terminology that happens amongst the
different labs you can see that there's a lot
of variation and to relate this requires a
lot of human knowledge and that's really what
the neuron phenotype does that's the benefit
of turning this into that formal representation
it essentially takes all of those different brain
regions for examples whether they're specific
instances of a parsilation scheme or whether
they're generic concepts like neocortex it relates
those together it takes all the different ways
you could represent a molecular species to say
that this is for example a somatostatin neuron
and it says if you have any of these and you
have any of these then you're considered a
cortical somatostatin neuron so it basically
allows you to express that complexity but then
it does reasoning on top of that to collapse it
down to its universals so if you want to say find
all somatostatin containing cortical neurons
it can do that it can pull all these things
out regardless of the local terminology and it
does this through these ontological structures
so the same practice that we used for
relating experimental types and common
usage types in neurons is also something
that we did to handle all those different
parcellation schemes we basically introduced
two different types of anatomical structure
one is equivalent it's a common usage brain
region it's a brain region that we all talk about
it is in anatomy textbooks but essentially
it's stateless and it's stateless and species
independent so you can find anterior cingulate in
a whole bunch of species stateless i mean that it
it corresponds to a specific region of brain if
you're taught neuroanatomy it'll tell you where
it is but the boundaries of it are only generally
defined in specific experimental techniques so
when we say anterior cingulate and you say what do
you mean by anterior cingulate we can say well we
can't tell you without additional data all we know
is it's roughly here but we contrast that to the
parcellation schemes which again are like these
experimental base types these are tied to specific
species and representations and they generally
have atlases and borders that are associated with
them so the provenance of that usage is very clear
if i say neocortex you only have a general sense
of what i mean if i say m1 according to x then you
know exactly what i mean so we've kind of again
created the sort of dual branches one more
conceptual and general and universal and one
that's very much specifically tied to these
specific artifacts so this has been a very
useful exercise it's still in its early stages but
we've already been being able to show that it does
help translate for example between phenotypes
coming from the hbp the human brain project and
bluebrain project in europe and those that are
coming from the brain initiative and it lets you
essentially express all those complex phenotypes
in a common language which lets you compare them
and again we make no statements about whether
these are the same neurons or not we merely say
that they share or they don't share features and
we leave it up to the experimentalists to argue
about that but at least again they can look at
all the data as you remember in the beginning
that would let them try to answer this question
instead of having to navigate all that themselves
so i'll skip that one there so the next one that
i'm going to talk about is anatomical vocabulary
services in the spark project and this again is
tom gillespie and my colleague bernard de bono
and monique serlis ziegler who's a postdoc in my
lab and the spark project just to give you some
introduction to it is all about being able to use
neural modulation that is sticking electrodes and
various devices into peripheral nerves to
be able to relieve a variety of conditions
they've been sticking electrodes in and claiming
all kinds of effects if you stimulate the vagus
but it was realized again that we actually
knew relatively little about the autonomic
nervous system we've had general maps for 100
years but we don't really know the detailed
trajectories that these different nerves take so
the idea of spark is that it is supposed to put
neuromodulation therapy or bioelectronic medicine
as we call it on a much firmer experimental
basis by developing a huge knowledge base set
of data and connectivity maps that are directly
targeted to the autonomic nervous system so
this is being done through something called
the spark consortium there are well over 60 labs
500 individuals or so that are participating and
they're basically creating maps of connectivity
and physiology across 15 different organs and
systems all of this data is being made available
to something called the spark data and resource
center of which we are apart and you can go to the
spark portal and actually start to find this data
and see what it is that has been done i could
spend an entire lecture on this but i'm going to
go through it relatively quickly and focus more
on the back end of how we're using anatomical
ontologies to help enable all of the things that
spark needs to do so one of the big things that
spark is producing are these connectivity maps
it has an interactive interface which shows
the individual nerves that connect different parts
of the organs these these things are all connected
to data sets they're mapped to 3d scaffold and
also simulation platforms underlying these lines
is actually a very sophisticated model which plots
not only that structure a connects to structure b
but also the trajectory it takes so that you know
what nerve bundle it goes through what anatomical
structures it goes through so that if you are
placing electrodes you would get a sense of what
the local tissue environment is that information
is not available through this interface but it
is being made available through a knowledge
base of ans circuitry that is using a very
sophisticated model you can see that down here how
precise the different uh pathways are and which
which structures they traverse and this we're
creating a semantic knowledge base that contains
this information and i'd love to talk to you about
this but we're not yet up to our first release
so i'm not really going to talk about this in too
much detail but this is a place where we're really
using the full reasoning power of ontologies and
full representation to create a very sophisticated
knowledge base instead i'm going to talk about
the fact that because spark is producing so
many different things it's producing flat maps
that's producing 3d scaffolds it's producing
data sets that having consistent anatomical
annotation across these things and across the
500 people who are involved in spark is really
quite critical for it to be successful right
you want people to be able to pass easily from one
representation to the next and you want them to be
able to understand exactly what it is that they're
looking at when they see these structures so
we are putting spark from the get-go on a firm
ontological backbone we're using a community
ontology called uberon supplemented by the
foundational model of anatomy for human terms
as our annotation framework but as i mentioned
before those ontologies tend to be fairly coarse
and they don't get down to the level of detail
that one needs if you're producing this type
of detailed anatomical data and these and these
detailed route maps so one of the challenges that
we've had is how we go about allowing this fair
annotation to happen without being constrained
by what's available through these community
ontologies so one of the things that we did was
we've incorporated these ontologies into the main
segmentation tools and annotation tools that are
being used this is actually a tool that's produced
by micro brightfield or former micro brightfield
mbf bioscience which lets people contour and do
these detailed delineations of their data sets
these are all lists of anatomical terms here's
metadata about the species that is being used
but if you actually look behind the scenes
that's actually translating this information
into identifiers and so that mapping is happening
automatically when the researchers are annotating
they don't need to do anything afterwards
problem is of course is then they get d
deep in here as i mentioned they may encounter a
structure that isn't in the ontology so what do we
do in that case well the nif project cycrunch you
can see again both of these terms in here actually
maintains an infrastructure that allows people to
on the fly add terms to a database called interlex
receive an identifier and then later on do the
knowledge engineering to relate that to other
terms or even contribute them back to different
ontologies so essentially when people are
annotating if there's a new term it gets added to
interlex it then gets its identifier they're free
to annotate with it and as i'll show you we have
a review process later to sort of see how well
that goes um the full ontology is served through
something called scigraph which is a neo4 based
neo4j based system you can either access interlex
or scigraph through services if you want to
incorporate this into again an annotation
workflow like you saw with the mbf tool
so just to look at interlex a little bit
more it's essentially an online lexicon
or dictionary of biomedical terms it largely
draws those terms from community ontologies
that exist already maintaining the identifiers
and some of the relations it doesn't have all
of them but it has some of them but its main
power is that users can add link and modify
metadata within interlex so they can add their
own terms they can change definitions they can
do all of that basically they can do with the
ontology is what they want to do and all of this
is captured in um versioning number and provenance
so that essentially it becomes a sort of a living
laboratory of what people want to do with
these concept it's really designed to provide
the necessary coverage for this type of deep
annotation of experimental data without at the
same time we contribute to community ontologies
but we don't have to wait to submit those terms
wait for it to be approved and so on and so
forth neither if you're doing experimental data
even though a lot of ontologies have term request
pipelines you may have to use ontology's four or
five different ontologies when you're annotating
a single data set and you don't want to have to
go to four to five different uh term requests so
it's a very sort of powerful system but it's again
designed to serve as the interface between the
experimentalists and these community ontologies
so just to look in a little more detail each term
is assigned a a uniform resource identifier so a
full uri it's mapped to other terms if they exist
it's tagged with who it is contributed it can be
related to different terms if you wish those can
come in through bulk upload or you can add them
yourselves there's a commenting thread on each one
of them that can be used for discussion and it has
some curatorial tools so if for example like spark
there's an approval process for something to be
used or approved for the spark vocabularies there
are a set of curation tools that people can use to
say yes this has been approved or no it hasn't
again everything gets in not necessarily
everything gets approved so how does that approval
process work in spark we actually do maintain
something called the spark anatomical working
group these are a set of independent experts
anatomical experts who serve as consultants to
spark currently they're gary ma and jerry jackie
bresnahan plus a network of experts every new term
that's submitted to spark gets reviewed by sog
it's not a matter of them rejecting or accepting
them it is a quality control review however so for
example we had one term that was used to annotate
data called the thoracic anza it was brought to
the sog and they said we've never heard of this
term and we have no idea what they mean we went
back to the investigator and they said oops that's
actually a mistake that's not what it should have
said so it was able to actually correct an error
which is a very important there are other areas
where they suggest terms where one said they
wanted to call it empty area and we said does
this refer to extracellular space the investigator
said no no this is a fixation artifact so we said
well actually this might be a better term and
they were willing to use it even if they had
used it as a synonym right we would have had that
mapping but essentially again this is not that
sort of consensus-driven process this is just a
review for clarity sometimes we get terms and the
the experts say you know what
that really should be an uber on
uh and we recommend that we we go then go
through and we submit it to uber on so that
we build up their representation
of the peripheral nervous system
so essentially what we've done in spark is we've
implemented the infrastructure and a workflow in
a process for both being formal about what it
is that we use in our annotations but given the
flexibility to build content area that is not
yet in community ontologies and also those very
detailed uh structures that often are necessary
for annotating experimental data that really
don't belong in community ontologies for example
we get a lot of junctions between two structures
and it goes through again this process of
approval everything gets in to interlects
so it's available for use but only some things get
into the spark ontologies which get built into nif
some of them go to uber on and so on and so forth
so this is how we balance the need for formalism
with the flexibility that we need for
experimental neuroscience and it looks like
i have a few minutes to go through reapernym
so i will do that and again i think you'll
hear a little bit more about this from david
kennedy so this is a reaprenim which is the center
for reproducible neuroimaging computation my
colleagues david kennedy jeff grata satra dave and
yarick are all listed below and they
all know a lot more about this than i do
i do i am involved but not as heavily as these
gentlemen and essentially as you'll hear about
reprint m is again really geared
towards data and it's geared towards
making the process of acquiring and analyzing
neuroimaging data much more reproducible
so they cover the main areas study design
data collection data processing statistical
analysis and publications they provide
details on how you can do this in a much
firmer computational footing and a much
fairer way than we typically do it right now
but one of the things that's sort of integral to
reapernym is this idea of annotation right that
annotation of metadata all experimental
details do need to be annotated and the more
they are done so in a fair way the more that
metadata is available for downstream analysis
and comparison so annotation is very
very critical to this entire process
they are and what are they annotating to well
there is a core vocabulary i think jack was
involved in this called the knight em neuro
imaging data model i should say a data model
and that has data set descriptors it deals with
experiments workflows results it also has a
vocabulary that can be used to describe these
things and annotate these things it's based on
something called prov which is a w3c standard for
looking at provenance you can see what that looks
like right over here and it's a very sophisticated
and uh fairly complex model that serves as one of
the back ends for the reprinting strategy so i'm
not going to go too much into what it is that
reapernym does in terms of their technology stack
but one thing is clear right that there needs to
be a robust annotation framework this crosses
everything all right that one does this is the
annotation and you can see here that they also are
using the interlex system in order to balance this
need for formalism with the need to be able to add
things as needed in these very complex and often
customized workflows so it's the same
infrastructure that we're using for spark
one of the outcomes of all of this annotation
is that they are building a data lake which is
a public repository that will have all of this
annotated data in it they also allow researchers
to develop their own local data stores but
just as with the other contexts that we've seen
narrow imaging is characterized by a lot of
different packages there's a lot of software
that's out there there's a lot of customized
routines so fsl and ants and free surfer and
all of these different things are built into
different workflows so these are all being mapped
knight em and one of the things that one
of the places where ontologies are really
coming into play is in essentially annotating
the data elements that are produced by these
different packages so that's what i'm going
to focus on for the last part of this talk
so if you look at common data elements there was a
big push at nih to create common data elements for
different types of things there are data elements
that actually come out of these packages so
there's a tool called free surfer and it measures
the caudate nucleus the left caudate nucleus
volume so it basically if you run that package
you will get a chunk of tissue that corresponds to
the left caudate nucleus according to free surfer
uh you'll get the same thing if you use a package
called amps one of the things that jeff grata and
dave keeter have done is they basically are taking
these common data elements and they're turning
them into what are called community data elements
so they're taking the different pieces of these
data elements and mapping them to ontological
concepts that are relevant so for example the
caudate nucleus from uber on the left side which
is laterality the units from the unit ontology
so they're creating these sort of semantic data
elements that are coming from this so that means
that though that the ants and free surfer are both
now expressed in the same common language one that
is fair and therefore computable and formalizable
so that's one step the second step which i think
is rather neat is that they've introduced the
concept of something called a federated data
element so you can take these community data
elements that have been mapped to these formal
concepts and now say that there does exist
something called left caudate nucleus volume
and that can be expressed in free surfer that
can also be expressed in ants again we know that
there are differences in the way that these things
are defined and we know that there's differences
in the way um and probably disagreements in the
way that are and also measured right so these two
things may not be equivalent whoops i'm getting
to the end here but at least you have enough
you have the chance of understanding that the
left caudate nucleus has been measured and the
provenance of that is clear through these deep
semantics so i hope you can see that um this is
a use of ontology again not to drive consensus
but just to express and reveal what is in the
latent tools in a way that is interoperable
so actually this is good timing where
are we now compared to 2008 when all
young and fresh we decided that we would be able
to go out and create ontologies for neuroscience
well i think that there are several things that
are in our favor now neuroscience is going i
would say slowly towards fair but fair is tough
so that doesn't surprise me but groups that never
before cared about data standards or vocabularies
are now starting to talk about them those who are
developing the brain archives for example like
satrajin gauche are using ontology identifiers
in their data models so that again the
problems that nif had in the beginning
will not be solved but they will be less okay so i
think this is finally permeating the mindset of a
lot of people doing neuroscience but the process
that we've built the models the infrastructure
and for working and building fair vocabularies
we really implemented a process that we believe
is suitable for experimental neuroscience it
lets the experimentalists work where they are
provides these translation services and formalizes
knowledge about the the universals that we share
in neuroscience and doesn't worry so much about
these other leave notes because those are at the
cutting edge and those are tied to specific data
and data sets that we hope will also be fair so
that we can start to examine these concepts and
say do they have any validity or not we're not
telling them yes or no so we don't you notice
in this at any point insist on consensus at no
point do we have everybody in the room agreeing
on anything rather we align this common knowledge
ourselves with more experimental concepts
to promote search and interoperability
so the good news is is i think we are really
getting some tractions but also we still believe
very strongly in these community ontologies
they're very valuable and so all of our efforts
are enriching these with neuroscience content
and terms although using a bottom-up approach
instead of top-down and i think that's it
so thank you very much for your attention
maryann thank you so much that was uh uh it's
always interesting whenever i have students
come to me and they i say well what do you want
to do when you you know in neuroscience and say
oh i want to understand the brain right i think
just if you just kind of watch a talk by maryann
martone it'll give you a a an understanding
of the hill you're going to be climbing
it is a complex beast i you know you in your talk
which was fantastic by the way and you covered so
much ground i think everybody appreciates that
you really kind of made the linkage between this
kind of just natural linkage between brain science
with all of its different terms and it's all these
different levels of granularity and ontological
sciences um and how that relates to how you can
promote fairness i'm kind of curious what you
view as the connection to what we now think of
as data science we must once called it kind of
informatics but now it's really data science
where's that connection the computational
element of things i have my marvelous quote
somewhere let me see if i can find it i'll just
put this up because this is one of my favorites
i didn't know if i would have time to get to it
so you do see these two strains right which says
well i've got all this data all i need to do is
put this data together and i'm going to find new
things and i really don't need these concepts
right these concepts aren't really necessary
because i'm going to be able to look for data
signatures and everything i need is in the data
and i i saw this wonderful blog a few years ago
and i i took the concepts from it where they
they contrasted the semantic idealist with the
chaotic nihilist right and so you know the idea
and they said these are big data's odd couples
right these she's abandoned any hope of properly
tagging the world and relies on machines to find
the most relevant or appropriate information
her kind or the machine learning data scientists
are convinced that given enough data in the right
algorithm the best results will bubble to the top
uh and you know you you contrast that with sort of
the ontological world as the semantic idealists
who fetishize taxonomies we have to tag and
organize it all and i think we all recognize
that there's an interplay between these two
so um you know i always say render under semantics
what goes to semantics and render onto data what
goes to data and i think one of the problems
that the when i was first interacting with the
ontology community is their idea of data was very
different than mine their idea of data was this
distilled knowledge that was inside of papers and
i said no no no what we're talking about is data
is this right these are the numbers and these are
the measurements and ideally you want these two
to agree and that's why i emphasize now assertions
so when i take something like this and i assert
that it is something that we would consider a
universal right something that we understand
you would ideally like to be able to say that
i have asserted that this thing is an x so i've
asserted that this is a mitochondria in a in a
you know a gene network but you would also like
the gene network to have some validity that this
is a mitochondria right that it basically says
oh look right i've localized this to mitochondria
and this one has dna sequences that are have been
in the past associated with with mitochondria so i
find that this sort of back and forth you're still
going to have to take all this right and you're
still going to have to conceptualize it because
that's how human beings communicate with each
other that's how we understand but you really
want them to work in tandem and you don't want to
force one structure into the other let data handle
what data handles let these assertions handle
what they what they handle they handle making
it easy to search because even though everybody
wants the algorithm that's going to go across
the web and find data signatures right now that's
extremely difficult to do so if you are going to
search you're going to put in a term right you're
going to say this is what i'm trying to find
but if we get hung up that those terms are
accurate and all-encompassing we're never
going to get anywhere right to me these two
things come together so i assert that those
yellow dots are about something that i know
and in the future you would like to make sure
that any time you see that pattern of yellow
dots that it is tied with that assertion so
as somebody said once i think was jeffrey builder
who's from crossref he said uh if i assert
that i'm maryann martone that's one
thing and most of you will believe me
and i say that i work at ucsd you'll say okay that
sounds reasonable if you then go to a database
at ucsd and they say oh yes here's maryann martin
identified by her orchid and she does in fact work
here then that is a much stronger right bit of
evidence than just say so so i believe that these
assertions again provide us a way of communicating
about meaning they help in search but ultimately
you want them all to be able to agree with each
other so that's why i really emphasize that
if i go to five different databases with five
different bunds of yellow dots and they're all
in different places and mitochondria is scattered
throughout it means i probably don't understand
what a mitochondria is and i certainly can't
recognize it in data there's no consistency there
let's let's contrast that right where i say oh
i go to five different databases they all have
annotations on mitochondria and when i combine
those data together they're all pretty close
you know we're going to get 100 but they're
pretty close that suggests that the concept
of mitochondria has some validity in a bunch
of different experimental contexts and that
therefore it's a good thing for us to you know
build our theories on top of it so i think that
you know really what i'm i'm advocating is to
use them where they're appropriate but not to
worry again about saying oh this is exactly in the
right place of the hierarchy it's just meant to be
uh a way of us to formalize our shared
understanding of what all this data means i don't
know if that answered your question but i i think
so i love this slide it's very good because it's
it actually your comment leads me into another
question of you know these databases and uh these
various things like the interlex tool for example
seems like a very powerful framework um to what
degree does it interact with things like omop or
ohdsi that are databases uh in the clinical space
yes so currently we sort of sit in the
basic science spaces and um we we do not
interact with them um but there's no reason
why it could not right there's no reason why
the approach it it can ingest anything and anyone
can ingest what we have because we just need to
make the linkage you just need to make the linkage
yeah okay uh one final thing and i always kind of
use this as a joke when i'm giving a presentation
on it is when i discuss the fair principles
i say that uh fair uh it's unappreciated but fair
has a silent e on the end and that e stands for
education or educational in that uh it can be
findable accessible interoperable reusable and
educational do you find that there is um a role
for fairness in education both kind of uh on the
giving end and on the receiving end if you know
what i mean yes so actually i gave uh we had a
summer of data program through uc through dknet
where uh we take in student interns and instead
of doing data science which is what they expect
we do data fundamentals like data management
fair data and all the things that are necessary
so one of the sayings that i have is you know you
have to prepare to share and you have to prepare
to share fair because it requires effort on your
part and that fairness can be sharing just with
or that sharing can be just with your colleagues
or your pi or it can be with the world in general
but i was very surprised in all the lectures the
one that the students liked the most was the
fair lecture i gave because i think it started
them to sort of think about again data as more of
a primary product of their research and not the
thing that you munge and discard and then move on
to the next and so i think it puts data management
into a context that says well what am i supposed
to do in terms of managing my data it's like well
you know you need to make it understandable
you need to make it understandable to human
but here's an example and i use a lot of specific
examples of this is what's in your lab notebook
this is a shorthand are you going to know what
that shorthand means actually the shorthand is
a mouse that is from a catalog and you can use a
research resource identifier to put that in and
then you can use whatever shorthand you want so
i think in terms of understanding what it is that
you're trying to achieve when you're managing
your data it's very powerful at the same time
just like with ontologies i believe in what i
call the fair handshake right you don't have to
do everything you have to understand that if you
really want to achieve fairness you're going to
likely hand it over to a data repository or a data
archive that's going to do some of the other work
for you so you don't have to do everything your
job is to get it here i don't know of any student
who doesn't appreciate when i show them you
know examples of data with rich metadata and
data without rich metadata saying which one would
you rather try to grapple with right they all go
to the one with rich metadata they're like well
this one's much better right this one is much
better and so i think it both promotes their reuse
because a lot of the ones that have no metadata
they can't find it they can't open it they don't
know who did what they see that that data is
fundamentally unusable whereas over here where
and students are i think are really reliant on
using other data in many cases because they're
doing short lab rotations they have to do research
projects they don't always get to generate all
their own so i i do think it goes both ways and
it's a powerful framework for understanding what
we're trying to achieve even though there's many
ways to do it when we're managing our data and
then making it available maryann martone thank
you so very much for sharing uh this fantastic
tour of informatics of ontology design for for
brain science and just trying to get it organized
uh that is a hero's amount of work i have to say
um thank you everybody who joined us um everyone
have a great weekend we will see you all next week
in the meantime uh here on the east coast uh we're
digging out from a snowstorm and uh for those of
you who are also digging out uh good luck uh enjoy
your weekend we'll see you soon it's uh it's 80
degrees here just kidding in southern california
yes exactly all right thank you everyone